[Music]
i know that when he was a kid he had a
hard life and lying was part of his life
because he had such a hard upbringing
he's got some traumas that he's never
actually worked through either the
greatest gift you could give him would
be to stop using him
because you're getting something from
all of this
yo yo what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone's show for the third time
we had three false starts getting this
show off the ground today because
i wasn't at my a game but i'm there now
or i'm at least a good solid c plus
that's passing that's not passing when
kelly's the teacher
it's got to be an a-plus right
you're failing
right now
i'm totally kidding but you're not
really hey if you want to be on this
incredible podcast
clearly we've we've launched out of the
gate just rocking and rolling today
um give me a call 1-844-693-3291
it's
or 1-844-693-3291 to johndaloni.com
talking about mental health um anxiety
relationships family stuff depression
stuff whatever's going on in your life
give me a buzz
um education schooling vacations
whatever's whatever's happening family
boundaries let's do it
johndeloni.com
ask um quick reminder before we get to
the calls
please um leave reviews especially the
good ones the bad ones do not leave
reviews uh but tell your friends keep
telling friends about the show um that
it's just continuing to grow and i'm so
grateful we're all just kind of have our
heads spinning a little bit but thank
you for passing along and continue to
spread the word all right let's go to
terry in newport what's up terry
hi dr john thanks for taking my call of
course thank you how are you
i'm great how are you i'm just having a
blast
having a blast what's your life right
yeah exactly it's the it's that youtuber
life it's that podcast right
all right so what's up
so i'm calling because i would like to
get a little insight um
how can i help
my husband navigate away from the life
he used to have and the life he wanted
and the life he's living
and the feeling or need that he needs to
lie about things in his past and accept
who he is today
oh there's a lot there unpack that for
me yeah
all right so
um hold on before you unpack that
okay do you hear how much responsibility
you've taken on yourself
for something and i can feel it you
can't possibly fix
i know
um i just want to help guide him though
i know you love him
absolutely i don't even know where we're
going but just as you answered that
question
it's a lot
or it's not a lot
it's an impossible task so i don't even
know what you're about to ask me
um and we'll get there
um
but do me a favor as you're telling me
this okay
will you uh take a huge deep breath
and hold it for a sec
and then let it out and i want you to
drop your shoulders i want you to
intentionally pull them down like as low
as you can get them away from your ears
okay
all right all right you're carrying a
lot
that's helpful thank you yeah now let's
talk about it
okay
all right now we're going all right so
what's up
so i've been with my husband 12 years um
he's an amazing man i love him
endlessly um we're
probably like
i know there's no i don't believe in
soul mates but we're so greatly matched
that i just i want to help him every
step of the way but in the 12 years
i do i've obviously learned a lot about
him so he's he's this big guy he was the
football star you know um
his a game in high school
the only problem is he had a learning
reading and writing disability and he
was classified never able to have a
full-time job from his school
and he always wanted to be a marine and
he wanted to make his father proud but
with his learning disability disability
he couldn't pass the asvab testing to do
that
and so he kind of
just kind of skidded through life and he
had kids he had his first son before he
graduated high school and so he had to
go into the working field and so he's
never been able to really
grieve i guess the life that he wanted
and
he feels like he's still trying to prove
that he was good enough
and so when we met
i had he had told me he had he was a
former marine and things like that and
there's other various
um
non-truths that he's told me
and i've learned throughout our marriage
and it almost broke our marriage but i
also think he might also be on the
spectrum but he's never i don't know
that he's ever been tested for that and
so i just want to help him
to
move past that and i know that when he
was a kid he had a hard life and i lying
was part of his
his life because he had such a hard
upbringing
and um
he's got some traumas that he's never
actually
um worked through either so
i'm just
curious how like how i can help him
move through that
what just came to my mind is gonna sound
really harsh
okay
yeah can i can i just let it all out
with you
absolutely i'm gonna do this but um
we're on the same team right
yes okay
oh man
the greatest gift you could give him
would be to stop using him
okay because you're getting something
from all of this
all right and
whether it's caretaking
or whether it's
you get to really make somebody who has
never been loved feel loved and that
feels good
you're continuing to the way you even
phrase it you started the call by saying
how much you loved him and how great and
how wonderful he is he just has some
non-truths
another way to say that he's been lying
to you for the entirety of your marriage
not about trivial things about huge
things you married you married a veteran
yeah i thought i did yeah
i thought i married someone who'd never
been married before he had been married
before that's right
yeah
these are amazing
and i know you can say
the fact that you can say to your
knowledge he's never been tested y'all
been married for 12 years
yeah
you know what i mean
yeah
so completely the hard thing here is
you're getting something out of this
arrangement what is it
i wish i knew are you getting security
out of it are you getting
lost i know that's unconditional
i know he loves me unconditioning it
unconditionally as well because i mean
our marriage almost fell apart because i
had to step away for a little while
because
when my dad died it woke me up to some
things and so i had to step away for six
months and through the six months he was
still
very you know
text me every day called me every day
need to know how i was doing
he was worried about me and my
well-being what were you what woke you
up when your dad passed
um
when i found out that my husband hadn't
served in the marine corps it was the
only thing i ever lied to my father
about and when my dad
thought he had hurt my mother had
corrected my dad on well he never served
so my dad called me and said somebody in
the family is lying about him and i love
this man he's my son now and so
i couldn't bring myself to tell my dad
the truth and so
it's the only thing i've ever lied to my
father about so
i had to step away and really think
about things and where i wanted what i
wanted um out of this relationship and
him
so that's what
i had i felt i had to do so i stepped
away for a little bit
so and
you it was hot it was hard um what
brought you guys to a really good place
now i do try to correct him on things um
you try to correct him how what does
that mean call him out on when he's not
being true like and he's not doing um
it's not i don't feel it's malicious
intent i just feel that
he has shame for his past hey listen
listen listen listen listen
you are not being honest with yourself
our past are real
and they cause long-term behavioral
shifts
there's a biochemical process there
there's a behavioral process there's a
habituation process there there's all
these different reasons
yeah i didn't even know about the asus
score until i started listening to your
show and i'm
i have a very high aces score myself and
that's what i'm getting at
somewhere along the way you came to
believe that this is what you were worth
and you're not
and if your husband's got special needs
and he's got learning disabilities
that prohibit him from telling the truth
that prohibit him from seeing reality as
it is
there's much bigger issues going on here
but your continual
um you continue to
brush
very hurtful behavior under a rug
because of things that happened to him a
long time ago
he's a grown adult with kids and a wife
of over a decade two wives
yeah
he's got to grow up
and he's got to act like an adult
and he's got to get the healing that he
needs to get done and he's got to get
the resources that he needs to overcome
his
um learning disabilities and his
learning challenges or as they call now
learning exceptionalities
and there's too many resources out there
but i don't know any
outside of some outside of the bell
curve psychiatric disorders
where just lying about big huge rock
things
is something that somebody can't control
and more importantly
because he's not on the phone with me
right now
yeah you
terry you're worth being married to
somebody doesn't lie to you about
everything
i know
and you're worth it's deeper than that
though because you can't put both feet
on the ground because you don't know
where the w which where the ground is
solid
and lying is one part of it what else is
there
um
are you safe
absolutely um he's i've never felt safer
with anybody um he is so protective over
myself and our daughter okay um he he's
i know it sounds oxymoronic with what
you just said but he's very caring when
it comes to me and my child as far as
whether we're loved and we're safe
um
but i just i want to help him kind of
see recognize what he's doing and
because i don't sometimes i don't think
he recognizes it
um
if if what you're asking me is how can
you help him recognize it as you sit
down and you say
when you lie i don't feel safe and i
don't feel loved
okay
and if you continue to lie and make me
feel unsafe and unloved i'm gonna decide
to not be in this relationship anymore
because you are telling me
that
um your feeling of inadequacy is more
important than me being loved and safe
okay
your need to make up stories about your
past and your present and your future
so that you don't have to face reality
makes me feel untethered and unsafe and
it makes me really feel worried about
our daughter
okay and then he gets to be an adult and
makes some really hard choices is he
going to get the mental health care that
he needs is he going to get the does he
have a job is he working
absolutely he's actually a foreman for
um our local government road great
things um
he does wonder he's an amazing worker he
he works night and day
you know to provide for us and
everything awesome he's one of those big
you know like how do you always talk
about you're a big texas guy and big
strong men don't have feelings it's
definitely
um
yeah so at some point and maybe it's you
you decide to go to a a a counselor
okay a therapist
um
have you been to have you seen somebody
um i'm looking into it i'm trying to
find someone in my local area what is
your uh aces score
uh it's a seven or an eight
yeah i've had a pretty traumatic
childhood myself okay
um will you stop looking into it and
just make a call
yeah
you promise
i do promise i've already done it taking
the steps for my daughter to have that
okay
you are taking care of everybody in your
life except for terry
which is a really common thing for
somebody who had to survive their entire
life
true
yes okay
i want you to love terry as much as you
love this husband of yours
i want you to love terry as much as you
love your daughter
because somewhere along the way some
things happen to you this should not
have happened
and that communicated stories to you of
what your value was
and it was less than everybody else is
that right
yeah it's not true
it's not true thank you
you don't believe me though and i i'm
okay with that you you will believe me
over time if you'll go talk to somebody
okay
yeah i did it when i was a child um
after certain things happened my parents
did put me in it um
but uh you know
financial things and stuff like that
can't always continue to do it now i
know i know it's it's incredibly
expensive and it's cost prohibitive and
it's
a national degr disgrace in some some
cases yeah i completely agree with that
but it is what it is it's where we're at
okay
um right now this is more important i
mean you've read the data on that stuff
i've uh
i mean
the likelihood that your life is going
to be
way more challenging and way shorter
because of those experiences
because your body's still trying to
protect you
um
i don't want that for you i want that
for your little girl i want that for
your husband i want you all to have
peace
me too
i know you do you'll be amazing i know
you do what's the one thing keeping you
from taking that step
because you called me wanting to fix
your husband
yeah i i want to help all three of us
you know um okay but i think you've
heard it said a million times recognize
the traits i think
um i know his sister had offered to
pay us or pay for us to do um couples
therapy and you know
he didn't want anything to do with that
he wanted to
work on it on her own
and i think i'm making some headway with
him but not
i am not quite there yet because i i
feel that we all need it
no
there is going to come a moment when you
have to say this is the way this is
going to be
yeah
okay
and my hope is on the other side of you
meeting with a good trauma counselor
and working through some of this
awful stuff that happened to you
and in addition to the awful stuff that
happened to you just parents dropping
their kid off at a counselor's office
once a week
um
and not providing a healing environment
at home
isn't helpful either okay
okay you've been through a lot that
little body of yours has been through a
lot
it has yeah and that little teenager
that little girl that's been protecting
you for a long time she's really
freaking tired right
now i can imagine i
she's she's amazing
you do
because she's you but you haven't
connected the dots yet and that's what
trauma does it disconnects us from
everything
that little girl is something special
and
so is grown up terry
and the only person that can't see that
is terry
do you ever feel like if you started
crying you would never be able to
stop yep yes
here's the thing and council is a gross
a word but in counseling we call it
leakage
you can deal with it and let it out
or it will find its way out and it
usually finds its way out into really
inopportune times
okay
yeah
to answer your original question you
can't
there's nothing you're not doing
your husband isn't lying to you for
anything that you've done
right
that's on him
those are choices he's making
and i've got my own stuff in my past
that i will never speak about publicly
ever i just won't
and what i'll tell you is
all of us have choices to make when
we're grown-ups
right yep
and at some point he needs to choose to
quit lying to the single most important
person in his life
that's a choice he's going to make it's
not because of his childhood it's
because of his adult choices
and you can't
fix that or heal that or you're not
doing anything wrong okay
okay my hope is on the back end of this
you're gonna listen back and you're
gonna hear i mean you are
you are
trauma 101
everybody who's hurting in your life is
your fault your kids are struggling
because of stuff you're not doing right
what do you need to be doing to help
your husband not fill in the blank lie
to you be disrespectful to you not pay
pay for stuff like you know what i mean
like all we could get on a list yeah
you at the epicenter because
everything's your fault and it's not
it's not
okay okay
will you say the words out loud i'm
worth being well
i am worth being well and i'm gonna make
a call
i'm gonna make a call and then i'm gonna
show up
i will show up awesome will you keep me
in the loop on how they go
yes okay
make no bones about it terry it's gonna
be hell going forward it'll be hard
okay it's going to be hard
if you think of it like this when you
have surgery
they actually take a knife and they cut
you open
to get out whatever's wrong or to fix
the bone that's broken or to get out the
tumor or whatever
they actually hurt you more
during surgery it hurts
and you bleed and it's tough
and then they take care of you and they
close up the wound and then you start a
healing process and then you go to rehab
and then all of a sudden you wake up and
you are stronger than you ever imagined
and it's time
i'm sorry that somebody hurt you i'm
sorry that somebody continues to hurt
you and calls it love
you're worth being well we'll be right
back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done
it's that deep feeling of exhaustion
after a long period of being overworked
and overstressed and just fried and most
of us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
deloney that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back let's go to
arizona and talk to jordan what's up
jordan
hi how are you i'm good how are you
pretty good
all right so what's up
all right my husband and i have a
three-month-old daughter and he's really
really great with her but there are
times that um fairly often he gets
really frustrated um so fast like so
pressured is so fast with himself when
she's crying that he can't
calm her or
whatever is going on and then he just
shuts down for the rest of the day
because in his words he thought he'd be
better than this and i've tried to
encourage him to tell him that he really
is doing great she's a baby she can only
cry she can't communicate
um and he's not really doing anything
wrong he just gets so frustrated with
himself um because he thought he'd be
better and he's so good with the nieces
and his nephews but he's struggling with
his own child is this your first kid
yes oh my gosh
can you have him call me
because i've been here i've been here
yeah
oh man um
and i've told him it's all so normal um
but he just can't get past it sometimes
in his own head and he just gets stuck
there like in his own head and he's in
his words he gets like depressed yeah
absolutely or so and then he'll come
back but yeah i just don't know and i
guess my question is how to keep
encouraging him without you know telling
him what to do or to be degrading
i want him to know he's actually doing
well and then you know not get so hurt
and like down on himself yes um
all of this is easier said than done
and here's my guess you said he's really
good with nieces and nephews is he the
is he like the fun uncle
um they're all fun he's one of um five
uncles so okay
yeah oh man all right so here's i'll
tell you because he's on the phone with
me so i'll just speak to you and to the
people listening okay
number one thank you so much for calling
this is a call one of those calls that
um
will
end up doing really well cause it's
gonna help a lot of folks okay
um
your husband has probably been telling
himself for a long time he's gonna be
better than all the other dads
and he is going to be the dad who shows
up and is present with his daughter and
he is going to raise a great daughter
right am i on the right track
yeah he's going to be the dad and he's
got some experience with kids
not real experience but pretend
experience he's played and got a lot of
laughs and done some wrestling and he is
the cool cool one of several cool uncles
and so it gives a false sense of what
the day in and day out is like and then
you have a newborn
that is basically like a wet potato that
screams
right
it's it's just like a towel and
i was wholly unprepared
for how um
what a complete failure i was but here's
why i chalked up
success to
i could get my daughter and son to stop
crying they would smile when i came in
the room they would always want to reach
out to me and even though i would never
say this out loud i wanted to be the
cool parent i wanted my kids when they
were like three months four months five
months old when they don't even know
what's
they know nothing other than food sleep
and
cha-cha right
um i want to be the cool i wanted to be
like the dad that the kid reached for
instead of mom and i would be like sorry
hon he loves me more or she loves me
like whatever
and none of that happened because i have
no food
none of it happened
and so here was a huge
bellwether moment for me
i came home from
class one day and it was one i was
getting another i was back in grad
school again like an idiot and
um my son was two i think
and i came home and he was waddle
walking you know as they do
and he could say a few words he's pretty
late talker and he shows up at the front
door as i'm walking in and i said hey
bubble come give me a hug
because i wanted to be that dad that
always came in and dropped all my stuff
and was present with the kids and blah
blah blah blah
and he looked at me and said no daddy
and he turns and sprints down the hall
in his little waddle walkie way
come to think about it our our favorite
game his only way of engaging with me
right
because i don't have
food
and
his way of engaging with me
was playing tag
playing hide and seek
playing silly rambunctious games
and so his way of saying i love you and
i'm so glad to see you was let's go
right into playing a game
and when he said no daddy and turned off
down the hallway
my first thought in my mind was of
course because you suck at being a dad
you're never here
you're not right and then this internal
dialogue about how lame i was starts
i'm gonna be a failure just like every
other stupid dad my own son doesn't even
want to hug me and now i'm off to the
races right and so here was a big moment
for me and i'm saying this and you can
pass this along to your husband just
know he's not gonna hear you there's no
way he hears this okay but it it'll feel
good for you to say it out loud
the phrase here
he doesn't get a vote she doesn't get a
vote why because she's three months old
and
she doesn't have permission to hurt my
feelings and it took me a while with my
son and then when my daughter came along
it was she's it was even more hard
because she she weaponizes love because
she's my little girl and she's hilarious
about it
um
but i had to decide my children don't
have permission to hurt my feelings
and that was the magic for me
and now i can say
um hey uh this is what we're having for
dinner
i'm not eating that it's yuck
um that's
not knock your lights out i worked
really hard on this i think it's
delicious and so this is what we're
having and i'm not gonna let you hurt my
feelings
because as a society we have decided
because your brains don't work properly
you can't drink you can't buy beer you
can't uh buy guns lottery tickets you
can't sign contracts and so why in the
world would i give you access to
my feelings and emotions you see what
i'm saying
yeah so this is something your husband's
gonna have to practice
okay
and that's gonna be hard for both of you
i do think it's important for you if
when he is unplugging and checking out
and going off
it sounds like he gets depressed can i
tell you what it really is it's a temper
tantrum
okay it's a childish response to not
getting his way because he wanted the
baby to reach out and hug him and the
baby just screams and cries until mom
picks her up
that's a temper tantrum
and he's gonna have to decide
all right i'm not letting this
three-month-old have a vote into my life
and i'm gonna keep showing up because
i'm an adult and that's what adults do
we keep showing up we keep showing up we
keep showing up i'm gonna change the
diaper i'm gonna change the diaper i'm
gonna do it wrong she's gonna kick and
scream even when i'm doing it right
i'm gonna feed with the bottle and she's
gonna still scream for mom and you're
gonna get frustrated and he's gonna get
but i'm gonna keep showing up and i'm
gonna keep showing up i'm gonna keep
showing up
right that's what parenting is yes
and what you all need to have the
conversation y'all can have is less
about how he's feeling because he's
gonna practice
over time not letting this little girl
hurt his heart right because he's the
adult and she's a child
what y'all you need to be clear with him
about is what you need on the show up
times even when you don't feel like it
here's what i need you to show up here's
what i need you to show up even though
you don't feel like it i need you to
keep showing up does that make sense
that's maturity that's adults
yeah okay
um does he get hard to be around when he
gets depressive
or gets it gets pissy
it doesn't really get pissy he just gets
so sad like it hurts me and i feel so
bad because i can't help him in those
moments yeah so this is a phrase
it's gonna make the internet's not too
happy with me that's fine he has to
choose
he's got to stop choosing sadness
okay and that's hard because it's like
you can't choose sadness you just feel
sad i'm gonna choose
or when that initial oh my gosh my
daughter hates me then it's very clear
no she doesn't she's three months old
she's just hungry she's she is in her
what the fourth trimester right
she's still developing right she's a
yeah anyway that's a whole other
conversation
he's got to start choosing to to not
just go down the rabbit hole of sadness
and worry and it's all coming down and i
just suck at this and i hate my daughter
hates me she doesn't right
no i mean and she smiles at him when she
smiles at me like she loves him and it's
very obvious but then there's the moment
where
she needs something and she can't tell
us and the switch flips so fast yeah
it's just a it's just a big kid temper
tantrum
uh
that he's doing and so and i say that
like having done a million of them
myself
and also
saying this on the back end of this
thing
choosing like making the affirmative
decision i'm not gonna let my kids hurt
my feelings i'm going to be the adult in
this interaction
my body relaxed
and kids pick up tension when you hold
the kid in your tents they feel that and
it feels uncomfortable for them when
you're relaxed and you're hanging on to
them they it's they can settle into that
and kids pick up that angst and they
pick up that anxiety and they pick up
that tense feeling those tense muscles
am i doing this right i don't know but
and they don't want to be around that
and so when i quit giving kids access to
my soul like you don't get to hurt my
feelings
then
i'd be much more relaxed and then when
i'm much more relaxed kids are much more
likely to lean into that and then with
my daughter i've talked about this on
the show
like age three age four she was so all
about her mom especially during covid
which they were at home together and i
was at work she had nothing to do with
me and it really was heartbreaking like
she would say daddy i don't ever want to
hug you ever
and i'd say that thank you for sharing
that with me and i'd go in my room and
be like oh i'm the worst right
and then you just hang in there and i
kept showing up and i kept showing up
and now it's hug fest 2000. last night
my wife and i and my daughter went to
get tacos and burritos at this local
joint here and i saw my daughter
and dude it was
she squeezed my neck off my body and it
felt so good in my soul so tell your
husband it's coming
it's going to come just he's got to keep
showing up he's got to keep showing up
he's got to choose
choose joy and choose choose to keep
showing up great great thank you so much
i'm so grateful for this call jordan
you're awesome we'll be right back
hey dr john deloney here and it's that
time again school is back summer is
winding down and it's time to get back
to the routines we threw out the window
back in may pick up drop off get up
early no more ice cream for dinner on
most days your schedules are probably
about to go bonkers but i've got a
reminder for you
for the love of all that is good make
sure you prioritize sleep for your kids
for your marriage for your job
for you
getting seven to nine hours of deep
rejuvenating sleep is one of the best
things you can do for your health not
doom scrolling on instagram or zoning
out with netflix all night we all need
sleep and for me good sleep starts with
a great mattress and that's why i love
dream cloud mattresses and right now
dream cloud is making it easy with a
great deal just for our listeners
599 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of 849 dollars in accessories and
savings i'm talking pillows a mattress
protector and luxury sheets to go along
with a great mattress so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress today
all right one more let's go to uh brad
in st louis missouri what's up brad
hello john
what's up man
hey thanks so much for taking my call of
course thanks for calling what's up
dude uh i got a situation in life i'm
looking to get some advice on how to
move forward with it um
i've
struggled with social anxiety for years
and now oh man recently
recently i went through uh
i'm just kind of emerging out of a kind
of a dark hole depression and social
anxiety
and i
what the situation was i had a i had
a construction company
and it totally
the the social part of it kind of wiped
me out and
i i had to sell my business and i got
out of it and i've been kind of
recuperating for the last few few months
here i've had enough money to be able to
do that okay
but
i'm wondering how to move forward now
i'm wondering if i should be you know i
need to find a job at some point so i
have to get something going here
yeah how long have you struggled with
social anxiety
i think it's been it's been since my
childhood okay is your heartbeat is your
heart beating pretty fast on this call
it is yeah yeah so i just stop and say
you're a brave guy okay yeah if people
have never struggled with uh social
anxiety before just imagine walking up
on stage buck naked
and then waving with both hands right
that's what it feels like just to go
have a normal conversation right
it does yeah so tell me um i want to
challenge you i'm a fellow anxiety guy
myself okay so is it okay if i push on
you a little bit
yep
you said you had to sell your business i
don't believe that convince me why'd you
have to sell it
i guess i made that choice to sell it
look at that dude you're already better
okay so why'd you choose to sell it
i just had so much anxiety dealing with
people that that i
basically felt like i couldn't
like like you said my heart was dumping
out of my chest every time i went to
talk to somebody or visit with somebody
or or deal with one of my employees okay
so
basically i i didn't have the mental
capacity at that point to deal with
anything
um were you the owner operator of the
company
yes i was
so two of my first jobs
in the university settings
were because my bosses were brilliant
and very
uh strategic thinkers great writers they
did not like public speaking
and that's why they hired me
they hired their
their the parts that were challenging
for them they would have been very
uncomfortable with all the public
speaking that goes into a lot of those
public-facing jobs so they hired me that
was my job and i had to learn how to do
budgets on the back end so my question
to you is
what kept you from keeping your business
and hiring somebody that would
help um do the things that you didn't
like doing or didn't feel comfortable
doing
um
even the thought of even the thought of
that at the time was too much to handle
you know okay
i i basically kind of
tried to do everything myself and i
pushed through i've done it in the past
i've pushed through everything but then
i would i would hit the limit and i
would back so
you know i i push myself
with
the help of lots of caffeine and maybe
some sugar and just keep going you know
yeah
but that can only get me so far you know
that's right
that's a strategy you've used for your
entire life isn't it
yes it is would you be willing to do
something different for the first time
yeah i would okay let me promise you
something okay
um
i had anxiety so bad i couldn't look at
a stock market chart like i would go in
buildings at the university where i
worked at i would go to different
buildings and take different avenues in
because i knew there was a stock ticker
in one of the
um
one of the like the nba classrooms
um i couldn't look at at tv screens
because i never knew if there was going
to be that little ticker underneath it
or the stock market on one side for some
reason
my brain i was in 2008 2009 it just it
just connected to that i couldn't be in
the room with it and then it got
prohibitive right because i was in these
business meetings we were talking about
the future of the company and all this i
couldn't do it i had to step out of
these meetings or i'd start causing
scene not a scene but i would try to
distract the conversation like and
that's just one of several okay so i'm
telling you that to tell you this
on the back i now work at a finance
company
right
yep like my boss teaches people how to
get out of debt and so
i tell you that there's healing like you
wouldn't believe on the other side
does the idea of sitting with people and
just having a hilarious conversation
um
and dumping water on somebody and being
goofy and having them throw water like
is that is that entire is that like
enticing to you like that'd be so cool
if we could ever do that one day
yeah okay
do you trust me that you can get there
i trust you but i i
trust
you're like nope nope nope hey that's
cool man hey that's totally fine you
don't have to trust me i'll prove it to
you okay
okay all right here's a couple of things
that you've probably been told us over
time um but i'm gonna say i'm out loud
again
all right and here's what we'll do we'll
cut this episode and i'll have them send
it to you uh today or tomorrow and you
don't have to wait for it to come out in
in whenever it comes out okay
okay and i want you to have these things
number one when you have social anxiety
avoidance makes it worse
and you start thinking about
meeting with people and then the machine
spins up right
right yep and then it spins up and now
you're worried about the machine
spinning up you're not even worried
about the people anymore you're pre
worried about the worry right yeah yeah
and then you open the moment the second
you open your eyes your heart starts
beating faster
yeah
is that is that is that your experience
yeah exactly okay and then once that
what happens is that once i get into it
a lot of times it subsides
yes yes yes okay
here's the challenge
it's it's a crazy glitch in the matrix
on how anxiety works all anxiety is is a
smoke alarm in your kitchen
okay
it's all it is it's just letting you
know hey we don't think this is safe
and it also goes off when you're lonely
and so if you struggle from social
anxiety it always is going off because
you're lonely or now you're about to be
around people and they're not safe and
now we're lonely and so it never stops
and that that what you described
perfectly is i just got to a point where
i had to sell everything and just quit
it's like being in a in a kitchen and
the smoke alarms going off and it's so
loud and your kids and your wife are
just acting like nothing's wrong and
finally you have to go out in the yard
because it's so loud right
that's what social anxiety is okay
you're not broken you're not deficient
there's just something in your head that
is identified the thought not actually
other people the thought of being with
other people as something that is scary
and gonna hurt us so let's sound the
alarms
and the goal is over time
to just teach your body
hey i hear that i hear the alarm but
it's all good
it's all good
and we're gonna teach our body over time
okay
so number one avoidance makes it worse
number two
curiosity not war
here's what i mean by that
when your alarm set off
if you immediately try to shut them down
to power through to push through to flex
really tight your brain will think oh he
doesn't hear me let's make him louder
versus
the anxiety alarms go off your heart
starts beating faster you wake up and
you can hardly drink your coffee
and then you get curious why is my body
trying to keep me alive there's nobody
coming at me with a hatchet what's the
deal here
oh i got these two meetings today
i love
dan and jim
and there's gonna be one uncomfortable
conversation i'm gonna have bill do that
i don't want to talk to that guy
or i'm gonna fire this guy and it's
gonna be really uncomfortable for me so
i'm gonna write this one down because
this one's gonna hard this one's gonna
not be fun you see what i'm doing there
i'm being curious with my body not
getting mad at it i'm not because when
you get mad at it then you start
pre-worrying about the worry that you're
gonna have about the anxiety that comes
later
see what i'm saying
yep here's the main way to say that stay
out of your head
do you keep something with you you can
write down
i don't no no i haven't okay i'm holding
this up if you see us on the youtube
channel
you can laugh at me all you want and i
wish i had a cooler name for this i put
cool stickers like yeti and like b
wilder and like uh
goruck stickers and stuff on it
because i'm trying to make myself feel
tougher you know what this is like if i
really am just honest with it
this is a uh stories journal a thoughts
journal
and anytime my body starts to take off
on me i just write it down real quick
that's it
and i got it for nine bucks at walmart
i might make one one day that's like 40
and make it all nice and leathery
but really i just keep it with me at all
times in my backpack
and i keep it out here when i'm doing
shows right here i might think of
something
like you really sucked at that answer
i'll write that down real quick and
here's what i'm doing i'm getting it out
of my body i'm staying out of my head
yeah okay here's the third word i want
to give you
practice
here's what i mean by that
you got to stop worrying
and worry is an addiction
and here's what i mean
have you ever sat in the shower and had
an imaginary conversation with somebody
that you will never have in real life
yeah
do you ever are you ever driving and you
start
rehearsing conversations you're going to
have with employees of people and other
contractors and your kids and whatever
yeah or calls with you
yeah how many times did you rehearse
this call
oh probably 20 times in the last 10
minutes before i was on the phone with
you so okay just listening to you talk
right now your voice is different
because you're smiling your shoulders
are dropped i can hear your shoulders
down as crazy as that sounds
what you thought was gonna happen didn't
happen
is what you think is gonna happen does
it ever happen
um
maybe a few times and did you live
oh yeah i survived it ta-da way to go
dude you already
you see
right okay so here's what we're gonna do
i read your book okay i read your book
about the about the backpack okay
and one of the backpacks that it feels
like i'm carrying is is
that
i won't have
the right words to say to people
i'm kind of a quiet guy
and a lot of times when i'm going into a
situation that's a lot of times what
is preventing me from succeeding it
feels like is that backpack
okay and here here's what's going to put
that backpack down 100 promise you're
not always gonna have the right words to
say
yeah and when i found
going into homes and telling mothers
that their babies had died or that their
sons had taken their own lives
that the fewer words are often the
better
and so here's a i actually if you go
back on youtube and look at the like the
trailer for this show
one of the calls that i made sure we put
in there was me saying i don't know the
answer to this one i've never heard this
before and i'm laughing
because my identity is not tied in
always having the right things to say
my identity is tied in
sitting with people when they're
struggling
you see the difference
right and so what i want you to practice
is not
not worrying about having the right
things to say because you're not ever
gonna have the right things to say
so here's a fun exercise i want you to
do this afternoon once you get a cinder
block
okay
and i want you to put a piece of masking
tape on it and i want you to get a magic
marker and write on the magic on that
cinder block
always having the right thing to say and
i want you to carry it around your house
for 10 or 15 or 20 minutes i'm serious
it's gonna be it's gonna suck you're
gonna be your arm is gonna be burning
you have to pass it from one hand to the
next
okay set a timer for 15 or 20 minutes
and then at some point you're gonna have
to decide i don't care to have the right
things to say anymore
and then i want you to take it out in
the backyard and i want you to drop it
and never pick it up again
and here's what practice means the
moment that worry lightning bolts into
your head
i'm not gonna know what to say
oh that's when you interrupt the thought
that's when you stop the worry and you
say i don't have to worry but i don't
have to have everything to say
i don't have to have anything to say
right now
because i'm freaking brad from st louis
yep i do and then you're gonna go into a
situation and hey you're gonna know a
lot more to say than you think you do
and on those moments when you don't know
what to say you can say the words i
don't know what to say right now i'm
about to get back with you on that i
need a day to think about this
and that's what you're going to practice
and you're going to practice and you're
going to practice until your body
doesn't sound the alarms your body
begins to know oh brad's got this he's
driving
he sees that big bear at the front of
the cave he sees that tiger in the field
we don't have to sell the alarm he sees
it we're good
now we just have to run or we have to
fight it see what i'm saying
yeah i do yeah okay
avoidance makes it worse
the one thing about anxiety is you got
to lean into the you got to lean into it
okay yeah that's the scary part it is it
is you won't die
you will okay anxiety won't kill you
running from it might okay yeah
you got to be curious and not go to war
with your body ask yourself why why am i
so worried about this
and number three
don't worry stop worrying and practice
not worrying practice interrupting that
thought pattern okay i want you to stay
on the line i'm gonna send you um i'm
gonna here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
send you three copies of redefining
anxiety it's a book i wrote before
um oh and your past change of future and
i want you to read one i want your wife
to read one and if you got kids
age 15 or older i want them to read it
and it's going to give your family a
common language that y'all could talk
about at home
here's another thing that's unpopular
and i don't care
it might be brad that you go sit down
with a psychiatrist and
for a season anxiety meds helped me and
again if you listen to show a lot i'm
not a guy who goes to meds first i'm
just not
but meds were helpful in turning the
alarm volume down for me so that i could
practice some of these things
and if you've been struggling with this
since you were a little kid that might
help and let your doctor know i let my
doctor know and i walked in the door i'm
not going to put a pill in my mouth
until i have a plan for us to get off
this
and my doctor was like awesome
and we worked together and it's been it
was fantastic
the pill didn't solve the problem
it just helped me be able to create an
environment where i could go get the
help that i needed and it was awesome i
got to talk to a counselor i got some
great friends i started exercising i
started practicing these things i'm
talking about here sort of leaning into
the discomfort
and the healing on the back end is
something you can't even imagine brad
just gotta trust me it's worth it
gotta trust me that it's worth it and
i'll tell you from
the countless people who've written to
me from all over the country
leaning into anxiety and changing your
thoughts
really working on it
can happen
and and there's peace on the other end
of this deal
so proud of you brad for making the call
so proud of you man
rehearsing tragedy is a waste of your
time
laughter and joy and connection are not
so let's practice and we'll get there
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show uh kelly decided to go
right here on the nose with this one
um are you a fleetwood mac fan
oh huge huge
yeah the uh the rumors album it's just
hard to beat that
oh i i didn't you have the word rumors
tattooed on your arm i didn't know what
that was about i thought you were like
just a gossip queen but very cool
fleetwood mac fan i did not
that is it it doesn't match with your
harry styles tattoo but
it works it super works all right the
song of the day fleetwood mac a little
bit on the nose for this show but the
song is a little lies and it goes like
this if i could turn the page in time
i'd rearrange just a day or two and
close my close my close my eyes
they said that a lot
but i couldn't find a way so i'll settle
for one day to believe in you
tell me lies tell me sweet little lies
you can't disguise i
can't finish you can't disguise kelly
just tell me sweet sweet little lies i'm
not gonna lie to you not on the show
we'll see you soon